are you into rocketry i started with
water propulsion worked my way up to
solid fuel then went back to water after
i set our garage on fire
nice i also tried to get some uranium
and build an atomic engine but that
stuff's hard to find
probably for the best
good luck millions of americans know
characters like young sheldon as super
smart prodigies on television well this
morning you're gonna meet the real deal
and we're gonna put him on television
that's caleb anderson he's a kid genius
who is not yet a teenager but is already
cruising through college courses and is
set to go to a very prestigious
university as mark straussman shows us
before he could even walk caleb could
astound people around him
wit smart kids apply every year to
georgia tech but no one like caleb
anderson he's 12. i'm not really smart i
just grasp information quickly so if i
learn quicker then i can get a head
faster this elite engineering school
fell over itself recruiting him plug it
in here caleb saw the labs he met the
school's president i have heard so much
about you welcome to georgia tech thank
you he's a perfect candidate to come
into our program and be very successful
is his admission guaranteed
i would expect that he would be admitted
for sure
admitted to study aerospace engineering
claire and kobe anderson kayla's parents
what's it like to be touring a college
when your kid is 12. i don't think
anything that caleb's done has been
normal for us
by age one he was reading this
fun fun
two he knew sign language and how to do
fractions
one
two
three i have this distinct memory of
going to the first grade class and
learning there everyone was way taller
than me because you know i was too i
could barely walk
middle school was awful it always is the
kids there they kind of looked down on
me
or they treated me like i was an anomaly
and um
which i kind of van he's taken college
courses for a year his parents now want
a university that's the right fit for a
tween genius
we want him to be an environment where
he's accepted and not tolerated if he
comes to georgia tech he's not rushing a
fraternity
i know no
i don't know we're definitely
protecting him make sure that when he is
an adult that he'll make a great husband
or great father a great friend
one day lots of people think they're the
smartest person in the room
caleb really is does that occur to you
you know what i'm i'm looking to college
and i'm 12 years old this is my life
this is how i am and i've been living
this way my whole life he accepts that
he's different full indefinitely smart
for cbs this morning mark strassman
atlanta